it is well enough that people of the
nation do not understand our banking and
monetary system
for if they did
i believe there would be a revolution
before tomorrow morning
the only real mistake is the one from
which we learn nothing
anyone who stops learning is old
whether at 20 or 80
anyone who keeps learning stays young
the greatest thing in life is to keep
your mind young
thinking is the hardest work there is
which is probably the reason why so few
engage in it
coming together is a beginning
keeping together is progress
working together is success
there is no man living that cannot do
more than he thinks he can
enthusiasm is the east that makes your
hopes shine to the stars
when everything seems to be going
against you
remember that the airplane takes off
against the wind
not with it
nothing is particularly hard if you
divide it into small jobs
if money is your hope for independence
you will never have it
the only real security that a man will
have in this world
is a reserve of knowledge experience
and ability
failure is simply the opportunity to
begin again
this time more intelligently
[Music]
the whole secret of a successful life is
to find out what is one's destiny to do
and then do it
if you always do what you've always done
you'll always get what you've always got
competition is the key cutting edge of
business
always shaving away at costs
one of the greatest discoveries a man
makes
one of his great surprises
is to find he can do what he was afraid
he couldn't do
if you think you can do a thing or think
you can't do a thing
[Music]
you're right
a business that makes nothing but money
is a poor business
obstacles are those frightful things you
see when you take your eyes off your
goal
education is preeminently a matter of
quality
not amount
the short successes that can be gained
in a brief time and without difficulty
are not worth much
the competitor to be feared is one who
never bothers about you at all
but goes on making his own business
better all the time
the genius of the american people is
self-reliance
america is not a land of money
but of wealth
not a land of rich people
but of successful workers
greatest thing we can produce is
character
everything else can be taken from us
but not our character
the unhappiest man on earth is the one
who has nothing to do
a nation that knows how to work will
never suffer
you